which is the most scientifically
accurate death destruction of a planet
you've seen on the big screen okay so
two things the death star planet if it
has enough we definitely death star
difficult to right amount of energy into
a planet you will blow up a planet just
the way it's shown yeah okay with all
debris flying pretty accurate that was
Hank you're probably the most
scientifically accurate part of star
that was actor now yeah and yoga yeah
now in the red matter a droplet yeah in
Star Trek the JJ Abrams Star Trek yeah
that one holding aside the unlikeliness
of ready if you turn applied it into a
black hole it would become a black hole
just the way they essentially the way
they show that that's sort of a cure
initially implode into it's assuming
that a red banner creates tiny black
holes that is a great plan example but
you need to drill it into the center no
just that's an honor you wanna join it
don't get me started
yeah oh boy okay once the once the red
matter is into the surface at all they
won't know that it's at the center how
was it going to know it's at the center
plan has no idea well yeah no they don't
they don't make it seem like this is a
read matters plan and they definitely
make it feel like a Romulan idea alright
no wonder they know right exactly any
other deaths of planets Superman
I guess the new Superman it implodes an
allele well no no yeah well it just fits
destroyed from within because they
that's more real is it or no they
Overmind
the planet so here's your people who
have super powers and super everything
and they don't know that they're over
minding their own planet I don't know
can you think of any analogies and they
can send the baby Superman Moses style
on a basket yeah a spaceship you know so
anyhow yeah that could happen if you if
you talking through it is unrealistic
you can you can destabilize a planet if
you make make Swiss cheese out of its
innards oh yeah that's clear but but I
like to star wars destruction because
that's good also good old-fashioned
planetary explore some energy into it
you blow it up alright
[Music]